-Guys, I want to play
a new game. "Voice Swap."
We're going to do a regular
interview, except, Mila,
when I ask you a question,
Ashton is going to
answer for you,
and you have to move your mouth
so it looks like you're talking.
And, Ashton,
when you get a question,
Mila will answer for you, and
you'll have to move your mouth.
It's like you guys are
ventriloquists basically.
Are you ready to try this?
-Yeah.
-It's the first time. I
appreciate you guys trying this.
Mila Kunis, how are you doing?
-Uh -- Uh -- Oh, wait.
[ Laughter ]
-I have to move my mouth.
You have words.
-I got it. I got it.
-Okay.
-I'm great.
I went to the bathroom this
morning and took a giant...
-Okay.
-And I feel wonderful
after doing that.
Because I released my entire
innards, and from that,
it just opened me up to the
wonderful energy of the world.
-Oh, my gosh.
Mila, what a great answer.
I didn't think you were
going to get that descriptive.
Ashton Kutcher, same with you.
How are you doing, bud?
-[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
Okay. All right.
Let's get to the question.
[ Laughter ]
Ashton, what music --
what music have you been
listening to during quarantine?
-Oh, you know, I just love
a little "Pete the Cat."
It's my favorite album.
Also, I listen to "Blaze and
the Monster Machine."
It's great. It really
gets me pumping and going.
I don't know if you guys
have heard of KIDZ BOP,
but, whoo, we love it over here!
[ Laughter ]
-Thank you. Wow.
God, I didn't think
you'd be that into it.
Ashton very excited.
Mila, have you been having
any quarantine dreams?
Like, what was
your craziest dream?
-Oh, my cra-- Ooh.
-My craziest dream.
Hm. Let me think about it.
I know exactly what it is.
One night, I dreamed
that I had elbow cancer.
I don't even know why I would
dream that I have elbow cancer,
but it seems
that my elbow was so --
You're not even mouthing it.
Was so cancerous
that I couldn't even bend it
and pick up my children!
So I picked up the littlest one
and dropped him
on his head again.
-Oh, my God.
That is a crazy, crazy dream.
Now --
-Are you even playing the game?
-No, I'm...
[ Laughter ]
-There's only
two more questions,
and then we'll be
done with this.
No, it's very good.
Here we go. I will say --
-I don't know how people
keep a straight face.
This is like -- Do you know
what my worst fear --
And I've said I'll never do it,
is "SNL," because of this.
Because I clearly --
I enjoy laughter,
and I have a very hard time,
like, holding it down.
It seems like --
-You and Jimmy on "SNL"
would've been a great pair.
-We would've done one sketch.
[ Voices overlapping ]
-I can never hold it together.
Okay, I got it.
-All right. Ready? Here we go.
-...'70s. Do you remember?
-Yes.
-Oh, my God.
Would get so mad at me.
-Okay, okay. We're in the game.
-I'm in.
-I'm sure you guys are excited
about getting back out
into the world
when this is over.
Ashton, what are you
most excited to do
when they open things
back up again?
-Oh, you know, I just love to --
Uh...
Boy, my favorite thing to do
is to, uh...
Just go outside naked
and run around and just
let everyone see my junk.
-[ Laughs ]
-...take off my shirt.
Look at me go! Whoo-ooh!
...my chest hair is shaped
like Batman's signal.
I have a permanent
Bat signal on my chest,
and I don't even know
why it's there!
[ Laughter ]
-Well, I want to thank you both
for coming on the show.
I appreciate it, and --
No, I'm not going crazy.
You're going crazy.
[ Laughter ]
-...crazy. This isn't crazy!
-We're so...
-We're fine!
We're just over here
drinking...wine! We're good!
-Oh, my gosh.
-Can't wait
to see you guys in person.
I really love you for coming on.
Thank you for what you're doing.
And thank you
for doing this bit.
Appreciate it so much, guys.
-Thank you for letting us
have a moment of interaction.
-Best to the fam.
Bye, guys. Thank you.
-Bye!
-Bye.